[Music]
malcolm is with us malcolm is in
springfield missouri hey malcolm how are
you
i'm great uh what an honor i'm a little
nervous i hope i don't blow this you're
not gonna blow it we're here we're here
for you bro how can we help you
okay dave
i am 65 years old i've uh
you know been pretty frugal my wife and
i all of our lives never took big
vacations or anything
and tried to save we're i'm at a point
where
you know a year and a half from now or
into next year i'll be at full security
retirement age
and
i'm really starting to worry now we've
i've got 401k and other retirements uh
everything i've got is a total of about
1.2 million now that sounds oh my god uh
you know you're you're a blessed guy and
i truly am blessed however
we know a million dollars isn't what it
was 10 years ago very true
frankly frankly i'm scared i'm scared
about retiring
what's your household income now
it has averaged about 250
uh over there
you know over the last several years
congratulations you've had a great
career yes okay so if you retire and you
have only social security coming in
you're going to start to draw the income
at least off of this but that's not
going to produce 250 000 a year
and we don't need it
but what do you need
1100
uh
yes
what are the mutual mutual funds
invested in
well there's just uh uh i usually an
investment company and
you know and i i can't tell you off the
top of my head exactly you don't know
you need to know that's part of what's
scaring you you don't know what's going
on
right you need to get with your guy on
the phone today
and say i'm scared you need to explain
to me what my money's invested in and
you need to be in good growth stock
mutual funds with long track records and
then ask the goob what your track record
is on your mutual funds
and let's say you're in a series of
mutual funds properly invested and that
the last 30 years the track record has
been 11 on the portfolio that you hold
that would be a reasonably invested set
of mutual funds
okay
okay eleven percent of a million dollars
is 110 000.
okay
but what's in the climate that we're in
well yeah it's down 20 since the first
of the year the big bad bears out right
but that's not the point the point is
over the next 20 years
un unless the american economy collapses
which i am not predicting and i hope
you're not if you are you need to quit
watching the news
um that's the other thing about fear
that means you're watching too much news
turn the news off but the uh uh
because their job is to make you
terrified so you keep more fear porn but
the uh um anyway the the uh
uh over a period of time
you're gonna make an average of 11 or 12
percent that's a 70 80 year track record
on the stock market
okay so let's say you pull 100 000 off
but this year it didn't make a hundred
thousand so you dip down into the
principle some
next year you pull a hundred thousand
off but it made 150 000.
so you only pulled 100 off that other 50
goes back in to replenish the down year
you follow me as long as it averages
less than as long as you're taking out
less than its averaging the up and down
dipping into the principle and back out
it'll backfill itself over time does
that mathematically make sense to you
it does but and i know that's
historically accurate but have we ever
been in this kind of and
we've been a lot more than a lot of
glory that we're using oh absolutely
been a lot worse than this
a lot worse i'm not sure we've had any
dumber people in washington that's about
the dumbest group up there i've ever
seen but other than that
um i mean they're dumber than a rock the
whole it's it's like the island of
misfit toys up there but the uh um
but the uh other than that the actual
economy oh good lord go back to 1982.
man you're 65 i'm 61. don't you remember
that crap under carter oh my god gas
lines don't you remember interest rates
18 percent
i mean that was a lot worse
this is a walk in a freaking park
average bear market is only 13 months
average time to recover from a bear
market is only 27 bucks
so a bear is is you know don't let the
bears scare you
he's the opportunity to buy cheap shares
this is the ramsey show